think it's 99.999
the woman's fault if she gets pregnant
why do you think that because we are in
control of sex
we
one there's a million forms of birth
control
two you can you can
you get to pick who you sleep with yep
and three
there's condoms and four you can even
get an abortion
so i think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's
i think that men out here just shooting
up and random girls are dumb okay i
think you guys are stupid
so do you think so but but i would say
that the responsibility is mostly on the
woman rather than the guy
so i
i
don't disagree that culturally so
there is more power in the woman in
regards to getting pregnant
but to say that men are only responsible
for one percent of that i disagree
i would say
because it does take two to tango
because here's the thing right
it is true that most men would have sex
with anything yeah
but there are the small percentage of
men who maybe have a lot of options
wouldn't
they exercise
discipline especially if their time is
money right but even even if let's say
they were a condom right what happened
to drake
that doesn't count it does count that
happens to really successful men all the
time oh no what i mean is like that's
not that's completely on her that's not
even one person but that's what i'm
saying like even if a guy wears a condom
a girl can take it
it's true that's that's true that like
that's an exception that's that's not
his fault but i would i would say if she
got pregnant from that that's that's not
99 her that's 100 her yeah that's none
of him yeah i'm saying if it was
oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] you drake
no but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah she's
making that choice but he's making okay
but let's say she does who is the who is
the choice to take the plan b pill
who has honor who has the power to yeah
she does she that's why who is who has
the power to get an abortion it is her
yeah it's true does the man have any say
in that i agree so that's what i say
it's her own fault you could you could
okay let's say let's say
one you can track your cycle there's
only like five days
in a month or whatever that you're
really likely to get pregnant no it can
happen outside of that yeah okay but you
can track your cycle
that doesn't work what can you do a
condom okay
if that doesn't work you can get a plan
b pill
if that doesn't work next time around
get an iud if that doesn't work no no
i'm not done okay if that doesn't work
and you get pregnant you can go get an
abortion
the men have no say in this none i know
so so like that's why i said culturally
so i don't understand how these girls
are saying oh it just happened what do
you mean it just happened that i agree
that's silly like any girls just like oh
my gosh it just happened she got
pregnant like
you you played that part yeah here's my
question to you right so there's like
over 40 forms of birth control for women
yeah
if it were reversed there was over 40
forms of birth control for men yeah but
it was still obviously women who choose
who have sex with so i'm saying the
intersexual dynamics yeah yeah yeah
but in terms of culturally it is men who
has the birth control power not women
would that then change your position
with that who's responsible
and who's responsible
no because at the end of the day women
men have no say in abortion if you get a
girl pregnant and you're crying to her
and saying i don't want you to get that
abortion
there ain't [ __ ] there ain't [ __ ] you
can do you can't save that kid
and
so at the end of the day a woman can't
have a child that they don't want to
have
so i fully agree with that i feel like
i'm fully like that's my person like if
i ever got pregnant so i am sexually
active i'm not on contraception but i
tell men straight away i'm like come in
me don't come on me and i'm like but i
know if that if that happens i'm like
well it's my responsibility to be like
girl you're what what are you doing in
these streets
we're having a long host season oh my
goodness i have a responsible season but
i am i am that's why i tell you guys
that's why you can get one std that
ruins your life i've already had
chlamydia i got
i was 18 it was the second guy i ever
slept with in my life we were friends we
were xyz and then i get that text being
like hey and i was like hey he's like oh
so um
i uh wear a condom uh no okay
but that but that is what i learned
people don't know he didn't he didn't
come inside me either
okay but that doesn't mean you're being
responsible
but a lot of people if you don't know
the media is passed just through contact
they don't need to come inside you so
even if they've got come in here on
their hand
what would reduce your odds i mean at
that point at that point i was a very
different human being but i'm like oh i
had to come in but you're not because
you're doing the same thing now
well no no because i make sure that
everyone i make sure that everyone also
how do you make them get tested and make
them crazy really we don't say clean
either so i was an ex sexual health
professional we don't say clean we say
std free because obviously the opposite
of clean is dirty and we don't we don't
perpetuate that like stigma so i'll say
like
i literally will say to people and be
like hey i'll tell them i'm like i'm not
on contraception but i i get tested very
regularly wait wait you're not well
you're not on birth control
no
and that is because
i can't
and that is because it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
up my hair [ __ ] up my body it [ __ ]
up everything you know what you have
[ __ ] up your body a baby
but
i'm responsible for that i'm responsible
for that what income no no but what i'm
saying is
abortion the wrong thing is you know
what else [ __ ] up your body
abortion person yeah yeah and your
mental health this is what we're talking
about it's responsibility is that i'm
like if that happened so i tell men and
they're like oh pull out method or
i'm like okay like
if you do you want to use a condom like
cool would like i'm like yeah i'd rather
they did but if i ever got pregnant i
wouldn't be like well it's your fault
i'd be like no this is okay but this is
like point in case where women are using
abortion as a form of birth control
instead of something that should be used
in an emergency oh no no so like
fortunately that's it i'm 27 i've like
had a lot of i've had a lot of girls
like yeah um but that's it i'm like yeah
we will either i'll tell men and so a
lot of men a lot of men that i sleep
with
actually to be fair most of them are
like well i'm either not going to come
on you or i'm going to wear a condom or
i'm like you're just not going to finish
like okay
okay we'll finish in a another way
um
and if a guy is like i'm still going to
try and finish beside you i'm like no
you're not because like i'll call you
daddy but i don't want to make you a
daddy like that's literally like
i will say that to men all the time
i just want to clarify some
understanding so right now you're you're
in the streets right yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're street you're streaming you know
street but even that is that is a
judgment on women to be like hey casual
sex is not okay for women
i didn't say if it was okay for me what
what i'm what i'm what i'm judging you
for i'm gonna be honest yeah go for it
it's just it's just like this is so
irresponsible because if if i'm
understanding it right okay
so so you're sleeping with these guys
you don't you don't know them i know
very well
my god i love it i was gonna correct her
but i wanted to see how far this would
go oh god oh my god no okay no no that's
my bad that oh no there's that here's
the love here's the honor if you can't
come in here come on her i tell men
straight away straight away i'm like do
not finish inside me and that's why i
say
i'm like i will call you daddy do you
want to be a daddy they all go no people
you're only you don't have the more
condoms though your only form of is pull
out oh no no like they could wear a
condom but then then it's on the guy
that they're like well i don't want to
and i'm like you get to pick so like
like dude do you make them wear a condom
i don't make them if they don't want to
okay but then i i have the conversation
with them i'm like look you've got
choices either you don't finish you wear
a condom okay or you pull out but i'm
well aware that if they don't if they
don't pull out in time i'm like i'm just
trying to recycle too yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um i get tested very regularly that's it
x sexual health professional sexual
health is the one part of our health
that we are fully responsible for we are
fully responsible for getting tested we
are fully responsible for being here we
are fully responsible
i do think as an individual as a woman
if if i was to get pregnant from my
reckless behavior i'd be like it's not
on you it's on me i have taken that risk
yeah and i was like i'll take that risk
but because i am very comfortable with
the idea of i know that walsh is not
nice yeah i'm not here like if i get
pregnant i have an abortion yeah i'm
like you know what if like you don't get
in a car thinking i'm going to be in a
car accident but you know full well
every time you get in a car or you get
on a plane you're like there is a
low-key chance that this could not end
well for me it's just interesting
because whenever like i talk to people
about abortion they always um
make it seem like it's only used in like
chill but no not no that's not chill
that it's only used in cases of
emergencies and like like
all that stuff but and my feeling is
that it's more used as a form of birth
control today rather than and it's
usually because there's some form of
irresponsibility so rather than like the
exceptions so that is very much so i was
a sexual health advisor for the largest
trust in the uk be passed through the
british pregnancy advisory service i
don't know the number one i don't know
every single person that i know that's
had an abortion
it was like just them being
irresponsible like it was literally just
them being like i don't know a single
person well i know i've in my time in my
position i'd only spoken to one girl who
was like
oh yeah i need an abortion but i used to
know the b pass number but off by heart
it's something like oh three hundred
three hundred eight hundred or three
hundred eight hundred years oh i mean i
knew it off by heart but the first woman
i ever spoke to an assistant in abortion
she was a married woman
she had two kids her oldest son was um
disabled
um she was like even my daughter that we
had was like an accident but a happy
accident and she was like she was
sobbing to me on the phone she was like
in her late thirties and she was like
something maybe say that's not really
like natural if we're like sobbing like
like if that's your reaction to it yeah
yeah no no no but then i was like you
don't need to explain yourself to me i
was like it's not my business i was like
it's not my business not my opinion i
was like you like you've clearly had
like a nice night with your husband your
family like you've got a lot of [ __ ]
going on and i was like it's not my
business i was like if you want abortion
get an abortion yeah but then i've also
spoken to
some women who were like
really chill like hey i need an abortion
as if it's controversial yeah and
they're like
honey like that's
just just go just go on
you know you know my mom was in a
position where she like like most people
would have advised her to get an
abortion because she was 17 and she got
pregnant
but um by my dad actually at the time
and they actually ended up like giving
up that kid for adoption and he like
he ended up being like a really
successful like sales software engineer
you just got married so i actually have
a really hard time
with it because i feel like if anyone
was going to get it it could have been
my mom like she was broke she was 17. so
this is very interesting um i studied
under professor roger ingram if he's
ever watching which he might not be so i
studied um psychology of sexual health
and we did um my personal project was
outcomes of teenage conception yeah and
it's proved all of the research and you
have to obviously look in the bias all
the research shows that it's more
harmful for the woman the better of that
child to have a child and give it up
than it is to have an abortion what do
you what is what does that mean it's
more
like so the woman for the rest of her
life will be like did i make the right
choice is my child okay rather than
being like i'm gonna have an abortion
and this is why and so i think i think a
lot of times like again we're making it
about us when it's really it's not about
you because there's a kid in the picture
yeah so you can't you can't you can't
you can't then but then it's like why is
that kid more important than you
why i mean i think in my mom's case like
he grew up to like have a really great
life yeah yeah like and so it kind of
like rubs me the wrong way we don't use
the way i think i think that's like why
it rubs me wrong way the little bit when
people are like make it not a life
because like my brother grew up and like
yeah did all these like amazing yeah and
there's always going to be but this is
why so
roger and groom he's a professor he's a
professor he's like the best in his
field um he so he literally told
everyone he was like we don't use the
term pro-life right to be pro-life you
would have to be a vegetarian a vegan
you won't step on an ant but you would
care about that woman yeah telling you i
want an abortion because i mean you're
you're either pro-choice or you're
anti-abortion you're not pro-life
because
i need you to clarify that so because
i step on ants yeah that doesn't really
make sense so that's well then you're
not pro-life because that's our life
that's that's not a human life
so then you're pro-human life but then
if you're pro-human but like i think
it's like easily implied like like
everyone everyone
let me just ask you do you do you think
there's a difference between a human
life and an ant yeah i do but then
because it's still a life it's right but
i know but like you're just kind of
trying to get like a gotcha question
like oh it's clearly
telling you everything i want an
abortion yeah
why is her life less important
because i don't think just because you
have a kid your life is over
i also think i also think the argument
is that she's in that situation
because of the decisions that she's made
whereas
the consequences happening to the child
which is the only innocent party
arguably does that make sense but again
it's like if it's a ball of cells but
also okay what if she's on contraception
and she's taking away
a unique dna sequence yeah like a very
like you can see but then why is it
if she doesn't value it why is it
valuable to everyone else and then we go
on to adoption okay if these kids are
valuable why are we overrun in every
western community of like ch children
get that's it they get you so you think
the kids aren't valuable if they're poor
i think they're valuable but they're
clearly not being adopted by people who
are pro-life
they're they are there my parents are
pro-life they adopted three kids and you
gave up one but that's that's just your
personal experience right there's a lot
of people that want to adopt like even
now like yeah it's like
could you let me finish um sorry but the
problem is that like the legal systems
are aren't don't make it easy yeah no so
a lot like there's
families that have been waiting for
years to adopt but like they want a baby
they don't want a kid that's been
waiting for years oh for sure that's i
mean i've seen like i've actually seen
the negative like consequences of
getting a kid that's too old it's really
hard to d like if you if you get them
past a certain age a lot of them come
with a lot of issues yeah like this is
it yeah professor was drinking all of
them
i think ideally like it would be better
if the kids were adopted earlier rather
than like growing up in foster care
that's not good for any kid yeah but
then they don't get a choice in that
they don't get a say when they're born
that's just a decision made for them by
being forced to be born and there's a
lot of people who
will joke and be like i didn't ask to be
born so i was suicidal for three years
and i was like i didn't ask you to be
born and my mum will say to me my mom is
quite unwell at the moment my mom will
say to me i wish i would she was like i
wish i bought you yeah that's really sad
yeah but i know she doesn't mean it i
know she loves me but she's like i have
so much guilt and she was a mum who
carried us to term who looks after us
and she's like i still feel like i can't
provide for you and i'm like no i get it
i understand that you would
not have a lot of guilt you wouldn't
have a lot of like responsibilities like
expert said
um but um again it's like it's all to a
difference i understand that for a lot
of people they're successful stories for
a lot of people
um but for myself individually yeah it's
just very i'm very pro-choice yeah it's
it's not black and white it's just like
almost like we focus on like the
negative stories rather than the
positive like even when me and you
talking about this now like your focus
immediately is well there's all these
kids in foster care that can't get
adopted rather than like the story i
just told you of the three like right
you know it's just weird how like that
that's your immediate focus rather like
there's both you know what i mean i i i
have a question just played devil's
advocate um do you do you think there is
any circumstance where it is better for
a human being not to be born
than
to have a life no matter how much
suffering there is in it oh that's
really hot like let's talk about ukraine
right now
like oh i'll give you i'm giving him a
better i'll give you i'll give you a
better example let's talk about slavery
would you say it was better for
a child slave to not be born
than to be born and go through slavery
but then potentially have the chance for
freedom depending oh
that's really hard that's uh it's very
subjective it's very like
because there are some people who go
through [ __ ]
and they're like um so statistically and
anthropology like anthropology
the highest quality of life is seen in
less economically developed countries so
people in like uh nigeria and ethiopia
are actually happier than those of us in
western societies and they've got much
less
and it's because you know the little
things mean more to them so it's like
we look at them as quote-unquote charity
they have more meaning in their lives we
look at them as like quote-unquote
charity cases and a lot of westernized
people are like oh africa is poor africa
is excellent but actually they're very
happy they're very happy with a lot less
than what we are and it's very
subjective it's very like
i do not have the
um
do not have the power to determine what
makes a good life to anyone but myself
but i'm just i'm just asking the
question i'm gonna ask you as well like
do you is there any
is there any circumstance where you
believe that a life being unborn is
better than the life not being born so
a big thing i
love um but yes or no
um i i don't i say i don't have a black
or white yes or no but a big thing a big
fact is so in i believe it's sweden 100
of embryos screened for down syndrome
are aborted 100 percent
because they believe an individual with
down syndrome
won't have a good quality of life
and i fully disagree i work a lot with
people with developmental disabilities
and so people are like oh so if you go
and um i interviewed cambridge and they
said this is the evidence that if you
have if you're pregnant and you live in
a uh built up area and uh carbon
emissions it means you're more likely to
have a child with autism and they said
okay discuss this with me and i went i'm
not gonna discuss it and they were like
okay why and i said okay so you're
telling me if i live here you want me to
argue about whether or not my child is
more or less likely to have autism and i
just went it doesn't matter to me and
they're like why and i was like because
if my child has autism i don't care i
will love my child regardless of how
it's born yeah yeah
i just don't understand how you can't
answer that question because nothing's
black or white yes or no it kind of is
like you can either think of an example
or you can't
i can think of an example for pro and
example for con as in like can you
is there any example where you can think
of
that a life has so much suffering it was
better that life was never born in the
first place
yeah i could think that but then i could
think the opposite so you can have
something so then so i would then say so
the answer to your question then the
answer to the question originally is
yes as in you do believe that a life it
is better you do believe there's a
situation
where it is better for a life not to be
born if its life was to entail so much
suffering
but then that is dependent upon my own
bias and my own
yeah yeah ah like that's it you say
slavery obviously you'd be like i
wouldn't want anyone to go through
slavery but then there are people who go
through slavery who could be like well
actually
this is my reality however xyz is good
about my life so in
spite of slavery
i've got a good quality of life like
it's so who am i to tell you that your
life isn't good like oh no we're just
not just asking for like okay yes or no
it's all it is
all it is is that can can you think of a
situation
where in your opinion it was better
for that person not to be born than to
go through what they went through in
life
i can't well then i would say that
if you can't then i would say the answer
to that is no then you believe that no
matter what suffering that life may go
through you believe that it that human
being being born will always be better
than not being born
but no i don't because that's it
no i don't because that's it it's not
black or white it's not yes or no
everything is the middle part of
everything like not everything but
technically everything is the gray area
because i can say for my opinion so
that's it my mom didn't want me to be
born she's she had a mental breakdown
two years ago and was like i wish i
never had any any of you and i'm there
like my life is really good and in her
mind she's like your life is [ __ ] right
your projection is [ __ ] and i'm like no
helen like my life is really good
and so
who am i to tell who am i to decide ah
so this is i think it's women i think i
think it's women a lot of times when you
have to admit something that kind of
goes against your belief system we try
to avoid the question and i think if you
if you said that like in essence like
you'd be admitting to something against
your belief no i think that's just
that's because it's the idea
we don't have a song but something's
like it's a little grounded but it's a
black or white question
but um nothing is backwards so i did
yeah dialectical behavior therapy and
it's all right with dbt and it's all do
with no we don't have to be black or
white yeah everything is in the gray i
don't know what i don't know what dbt is
so like his but his question is like
really it's really black or white if you
can either think way of thinking
yeah just to say
you have to be yes or no black or white
i might wait for this for this question
for this question like it's either well
i was gonna say when when kit said like
oh no and i went well yeah no but then
you expanded upon it went well but i
don't agree with that part so i agree
with some of the no yeah and i agree
with some of the yes yeah so it's a bit
like it's it's not
i hear what you're saying i ask you
pearl do you think um there's any
situation you can think of whether it
was better for life not to be born than
to experience that
i mean like
i probably would have aborted hitler
it's probably the only one
i'm like pretty pro-life but like i
probably would have aborted now
like knowing what i know now
um but i mean without like
you can't possibly know so i would say
no
like i can't think of an example other
than hitler yeah
maybe maybe or you know maybe like a
couple brutal murders like i watched
true crime
like what's the difference between
murder and just execution really it's
just perspective i think
[Music]
but then can we appreciate that that's
not a hard no because you've got an
exception that's a great area that's the
venn diagram i was just i was just
trying to be funny but here i was just i
was just trying to be funny yeah but
there's there's some truth in it because
you're saying do you know what because
because in the case of abortion like you
don't know you're never gonna know no
you don't so so what i'm saying is like
i actually
i actually wouldn't abort like hitler
well i'd only avoid him knowing what i
know now but that's not a real situation
right so like like and honestly like i
don't think we have the right to play
god
because that's what you're doing you're
playing god then do you believe that
that all depends on if you believe in
god not really i do yeah yeah that's
true
that's true
i'm gonna read some super chats